[Music]
Jupiter is shrinking too slowly for us
to see but we can see the effect of this
rising heat this is actually one of the
reasons jupiter has the spectacular
weather all of those beautiful bands of
clouds
on earth the sun's heat drives our
weather switch off the Sun and our
weather would stop but Jupiter's weather
would keep on going it's weather doesn't
come from the Sun it comes from deep
inside the planet itself heat rises up
through the boiling soup of gas churning
its cocktail of volatile chemicals
creating Jupiter's spectacular swirling
clouds
[Music]
and the whole time the giant planet
spins at 29,000 miles an hour Jupiter
rotates faster than any other planets in
our solar system
Jupiter rotates on its axis about once
every nine hours compared to a 24-hour
day for us so huge superheated clouds
from the interior gets smeared out by
the rotation and we have the beautiful
cloud tops of Jupiter this marriage of
heat and motion spawns a monster
Jupiter's red spot is a gigantic cyclone
larger than the size of the earth and
has been rotating stabili with winds in
excess of 250 miles per hour for over
three centuries imagine a storm that
lasts for 300 years on earth
cyclones die when they hit land but
Jupiter has no land to stop it storms
almost unlimited heat to fuel them and a
rapid rotation
jupiter is basically stoking the fires
of the Great Red Spot
we're used to storms growing and then
going away on earth but if they're
spinning the right way because Jupiter
is so big and spinning so quickly they
feed into each other and it keeps the
storm alive